à l'heure des téléchargements sauvage
sur internet de centaines de millions de
fichiers chaque mois les auteurs de
films et de musique tente de protéger
leurs créations un débat s'ouvre en ce
sens à l'assemblée nationale demain les
producteurs dénoncent des abus
christelle meyrals stéphane taponier ils
sont ingénieurs enseignants étudiants et
ils ont un point commun ils se
mobilisent contre le projet de loi qui
réglemente les droits d'auteur sur
internet
le texte prévoit notamment de murs
contrôler les copies de musique et de
films
mais pour ses internautes cela va
beaucoup limiter l'usagé privé des
oeuvres acquises en toute légalité
par exemple si on achète une chanson en
ligne le nombre de copies vers d'autres
ordinateurs et destinataire pourra être
limitée au nombre de cinq
grâce à des systèmes de cryptage pour le
collectif et plusieurs associations
c'est un recul avant un consommateur qui
a acheté un cd pouvait l'utiliser comme
il le voulait le transporter le mettre
sur plusieurs platine différentes
l'amener à l'étranger le copier dix ou
vingt fois tant que ça rester dans la
sphère privée et que c'était pas à usage
commercial faire de l'argent il avait
cette liberté d' usage dans sa sphère
privée
tout ceci remis en cause par le projet
de loi en cas de contournement des
systèmes de protection des oeuvres des
poursuites sont prévues jusqu'à trois
ans de prison et trois cent mille euros
damende le projet de loi intervient
alors que la polémique sur le piratage
fait rage en trois ans l'industrie du
disque en france auraient perdu 500
millions d'euros
le ministre de la culture entend mieux
protéger le droit des artistes
ce qui n'est pas condamnable c'est
d'avoir accès aux oeuvres c'est de les
rémunérer et pouvoir les transmettre à
des gens proches de soi ce qui est
condamnable c'est de vouloir globalement
échapper au paiement d'un droit d'auteur
parce que tout simplement sa menace le
travail des artistes et sa menace la
diversité culturelle
voilà donc vive internet vive les
auteurs vive le travail des artistes
mais face au piratage des associations
de consommateurs certains artistes et
député réclame une autre formule la
création d'un système d'abonnement sur
internet pour pouvoir accéder à la
musique et la copier librement avec